[Music]
farcry new dawn is out now and while
everything is initially familiar in the
post apocalypse there are some important
new features you may want to get your
head around we've collected a few handy
quick tips so you can get a leg up in
post apocalyptic hope County to upgrade
your home-based prosperity you'll need
ethanol in fact amassing ethanol is the
only way to get better weapons tougher
allies and even advance the story the
main way to get ethanol is to ransack
enemy outposts once you do that you can
take the initial ethanol reward and
leave it at that
or you can salvage the outpost turning
it back over to a stronger highwayman
force but you'll get a second ethanol
bonus you can also get bonus ethanol for
setting off no alarms or going
undetected early on doing this once is a
great idea because you'll still be able
to handle the level two foes and the
extra ethanol will help you upgrade the
buildings in your home base to level two
making you much better equipped to do
things like hijacking enemy ethanol
tankers or looting ethanol from supply
drops hello gameplay loop make sure you
upgrade your weapons workshop early as
this will be the best way for you to be
more effective in combat
similarly upgrading the training grounds
will make your guns for higher stronger
which will let them kill more things
which means they rank up faster to
unlock unique perks and abilities in
that vein one of the best ways of
getting perk points which you invest
into things like carrying a third weapon
or lock-picking is to diversify your
combat approach you'll get perk points
simply for equipping a new weapon and
taking out a certain number of enemies
so keeping an eye on this handy menu can
get you stocked up with points quite
quickly as for what to spend them on
make sure you get lock-picking or the
repair torch skill early so you can
crack open safes which are found in most
locations and contain a nice pile of
titanium eventually you'll get more than
enough perk points to get everything and
in the endgame you can even upgrade
certain perks so don't be afraid to
spend those
it's a surefire way to find both safes
and perc magazines that grant you pack
points is to do treasure hunts these
treasure hunts can be found a number of
ways but one of the most consistent is
through a lie Intel if you see a
friendly with a blue exclamation point
over their head go on over and find out
about a nearby point of interest that is
sure to have some payoff if you
investigate treasure hunts in particular
we'll require you to solve some kind of
puzzle but the fully stocked loot rooms
at the end are worth any head-scratching
once you get enough ethanol to spare
it's a good idea to purchase maps from
prosperity resident bane who once
recruited can be traded for Intel that
marks the location of crafting materials
and treasure hunts among other things
it's a good idea to pick up every little
thing you see as there's very few
useless crafting materials in Hope
County you'll need certain items for
crafting new powerful guns and vehicles
items for reviving your companions and
for creating consumables so keep your
eyes peeled unless you have an affinity
for sniper toting grannies or Molotov
throwing pastors your canine companion
timber is the way to go
your pup is able to dig and tag crafting
materials after he gets 15 kills under
his belt as well as enemies and alarms
if you're feeling like things are
getting a little say me in old herb
County take a trip out on an expedition
expeditions are wildly fruitful special
missions that take place on unique maps
where you'll need to skirt hordes of
highwayman in an attempt to steal a loot
bag and get to the chopper before you're
overwhelmed as an extra plus to building
up the expeditions area in prosperity
will also give you access to fast travel
be aware though the first level of fast
travel will only let you travel to
outposts that you have conquered let me
know in that comment box if you know any
useful Far Cry new dawn tips and how
you're finding your adventures in
post-apocalyptic Hope County
you